[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans europe
hebdo
au programme aujourd'hui plus de
transparence dans les relations entre
les eurodéputés et les lobbys de
nouvelles règles ont été votés la
semaine dernière que prévoit-elle qu'en
pensent les lobbystes eux mêmes on en
débattra avec nos invités dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission mais
d'abord ce sujet qui préoccupe toute
l'europe le breakbeat l'échéance
approche et il n'y a toujours aucune
issue clair à ce dossier theresa may
veut renégocier l'accord signé avec les
européens
pas question lui ont répondu les
européens alors comment sortir de cette
impasse philippe lambert c'est avec nos
pour en discuter
bonjour monsieur vous êtes co président
du groupe des verts à bruxelles est
également membre du groupe de pilotage
sur le sur le breakbeat je vous propose
pour commencer de faire un point
justement sur les derniers événements de
ces derniers jours pour y voir un peu
plus clair sur cette question du
breakbeat
[Musique]
autant
dans la partie de poker menteur qui
l'oppose à l'europe
theresa may jouer à quitte ou double sur
l'adoption de cet amendement
mais oui à droite 317 les noms à gauche
301 donc les ouïes l'emportent les avait
avec ce vote le parlement britannique
s'engage à ratifier l'accord sur le
breakbeat à condition de renégocier ce
qu'on appelle le filet de sécurité
irlandais nous allons maintenant nous
saisir de ce mandat pour obtenir des
changements juridiquement contraignant à
l'accord de retrait si la presse tabloïd
salue un triomphe de theresa may
l'europe voit les choses tout autrement
car le filet de sécurité a pour but
d'empêcher de revoir ces images une mise
en scène destinée à montrer ce qu'était
la frontière entre les deux irlande il y
encore quelques années
au delà de la baie c'est aussi le marché
unique qui est en jeu
la réponse des européens est donc sans
appel l'accord de retrait et le meilleur
accord possible et n'est pas
renégociable leveaux pierre accru le
risque teintes très désordonnée du
royaume uni en coulisses la menace d'un
bric site sans accord n'effraie plus les
européens
de quoi crisper les britanniques et les
rendre presque menaçant c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout ce qu'il y ait un
accord à nos partenaires commerciaux
entre claire et j'espère qu'ils le
feront savoir très clairement à nos yeux
il ne s'agit pas seulement d'une dispute
entre le royaume cela a des implications
dans l'économie mondiale au sens large
mais en attendant c'est en grande
bretagne que les conséquences d'un bris
exit dur se font ressentir
nissan vient de renoncer à produire son
dernier modèle dans son usine de
sunderland et les supermarchés se
préparer au pire à ce qu on fait cela
signifie qu'il y aura des retards
massive dans l'acheminement de la
nourriture jusqu'aux magasins
il y aura aussi moins de produits
disponibles une durée de conservation
plus courte moins de choix et si les
droits de douane sont rétablis les prix
seront plus de mille feux
un scénario cauchemardesque mais bien
réel qui commence à inquiéter l'opinion
britannique car 30% des produits
alimentaires qu'elle consomme viennent
du reste de l'europe
[Musique]
alors philippe lambert vient de le voir
dans ce sujet c'est la question de la
frontière entre les deux irlande qui
bloque dans ses discussions avec les
britanniques
on a du mal à comprendre précisément ce
qui est en jeu sur ce dossier en fait
l'accord qui a mis fin à trente ans de
violences en irlande du nord repose sur
une ambiguïté constructive autrement dit
l'irlande du nord reste au sein du
royaume uni mais c'est comme si elle
était rattachée à la république
d'irlande si vous êtes protestants vous
êtes content parce que l'irlande du nord
reste au royaume uni et si vous êtes
catholique
en fait vous avez reçu un passeport de
la république d'irlande et vous pouvez
librement circuler entre l'irlande du
nord et l'iran c'est comme si on avait
réunifier l'île et cette ambiguïté
repose sur l'appartenance commune du
royaume uni et de la république
d'irlande à l'union européenne dès
l'instant où le royaume uni se retire il
doit quelque part en place et ce morceau
de fondations qu'il est en train de
retirer et c'est ça qu'on appelle le
baxo autrement dit si vous voulez qu'il
n'y ait pas de frontières entre
l'irlande du nord et la république eh
bien il faut qu'il y ait un alignement
réglementaire et un alignement en termes
de droits de douane entre les deux
parties de l'île et donc les européens
avaient proposé d'avoir un arrangement
particulier pour les joueurs du nord et
ce sont les britanniques qui ont dit non
nous ne voulons pas de traitement
différencié entre l'irlande du nord et
le reste du royaume uni et donc c'est
tout le royaume uni qui va devoir rester
très étroitement associé à l'union
européenne
et c'est ça que les briques sitters ne
veulent pas ils ne veulent pas sauf
qu'ils sont liés par les accords de paix
d'il ya 30 ans et donc de d'il ya 20 ans
et donc il n'est pas question évidemment
de les envoyer au diable donc en réalité
le royaume uni ne pourra jamais se
séparer nettement de l'union européenne
à moins évidemment de de ceux de se
délier de ses obligations au titre des
accords du peuple de paris en irlande
alors theresa may a évoqué je cite un
des arrangements alternatif pour
remplacer ou pour modifier ce filet de
sécurité irlandaise la formule est très
flou est ce qu on a une idée concrète de
ce à quoi pourrait ressembler ces
arrangements alternatif d'abord le terme
arrangements alternatif figure déjà dans
le traité de séparation et donc c'est
pas une nouveauté ça fait plus plus d'un
an que les négociateurs britanniques et
européens se sont gratté la tête dans
tous les sens pour trouver une formule
alternative au filet de sécurité le
landais et
n'y en a pas il n'y en a pas et donc ça
relève de la pensée magique ou plutôt du
déni de réalité
le fait est que au moins l'irlande du
nord va devoir rester très étroitement
associé au marché intérieur et à l'union
douanière c'est un fait il n'y a pas
moyen de le contourner
alors du côté des européens on campe sur
une ligne rouge très clair on heureux
négocie pas l'accord qui a été a été
signé mais on peut renégocier l'accord
la déclaration politique qui est à côté
de cet accord
est ce qu'on peut espérer une solution à
travers une rénovation de cette
déclaration avait nos sont complètement
ouvert à renégocier la déclaration
politique qui quelque part
déclare nos intentions en vue d'une
future relation mais ça n'a pas de
caractère juridiquement contraignant et
donc moins ça ne répond pas l'habitude
de theresa may mais ça ne répond pas à
la demande des briques sitters qui en
fait n'accepte pas la réalité des
contraintes de l'accord du vendredi
saint
mais il faut bien réaliser que ce que
l'herbe résitance nous demande à nous et
c'est là qu'on comprend la difficulté
pour les européens c'est de dire voilà
le royaume uni soeur de l'union
européenne va faire ses propres était
libre échange va adopter ses propres
régulation et quand vous les écoutez
clairement c'est réduire les niveaux de
protection sociale environnementale
transformer le royaume uni en une sorte
de paradis fiscal géant pour les riches
et pour les multinationales mais nous
devrions et c'est ce qu'ils nous
demandent
accepter de ne pas contrôler la
frontière entre l'irlande du nord est et
la république d'irlande et docks entre
le royaume uni et l'union européenne
concrètement qu'est-ce qui nous demande
laissez-nous diverger complètement
dérégulation européenne et laisser
rentrer son contrôle n'importe quel bien
sur le territoire de l'union européenne
ce qui veut dire en fait dynamité votre
marché intérieur et c'est évidemment il
ne peut pas en être question et c'est là
qu'il faut bien comprendre et je pense
qu'on le sous-estiment au royaume-uni
que à choisir entre deux maux l'un étant
à bréxent it100 hackers qui aura des
conséquences économiques et pratiques
dommageables pour les états riverains du
royaume uni et une dynamite âge du
marché intérieur
mais les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
et le parlement ont vite choisi de deux
mots nous choisissons le moindre ce ne
soit pas un break si dur ne sera pas
agréable mais on ne va quand même pas
saper une fondation de l'union
européenne c'est clairement ce qui a dit
michel barnier devant les commissaires
européens le 30 janvier dernier le plus
coûteux le plus grave ce n'est pas un
président sans accord pour l'union
européenne ce serait là
destruction du marché en volume en ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'un brésil
dur ça ne fait plus peur aux européens
c'était un peu la carte maîtresse de
theresa may dans dans les discussions
mais oui mais mais enfin ça ne nous
réjouit pas nous voyons bien le problème
et il faut pas faut pas sous-estimer les
conséquences d'un break site sans accord
ça veut dire que les relations entre le
royaume uni et les vingt-sept vont être
pourri pour une durée relativement
longue et donc ça aura des conséquences
durables donc ce n'est pas bon pour
l'union européenne mais dynamité l'union
européenne elle-même parce que vous
savez dynamiter le marché intérieur
ça veut dire pratiquement saper la base
la plus évidente de l'union européenne
et donc dynamité l'union européenne ce
serait encore beaucoup plus grave
et donc voilà s'il faut avaler une
pilule on prend celle qui fait le moins
mal mais c'est une pilule qui peut être
très amer pour l'économie européenne
quand même malgré tout ça a été évalué
l'impact économique d'un brno il est en
fait très difficile d'évaluer cela
d'abord parce que vous savez que les
outils de modélisation économique
qu'utilisent la plupart des économistes
néoclassiques sont en fait à capable de
modéliser l'économie et donc ne perdons
pas chrono temps là dessus on se rend
bien compte on se rend bien compte que
l'impact pour la france pour la belgique
ou les pays-bas pour l'allemagne pour le
danemark sera un impact très négatif
mais l'impact pour le royaume uni sera
bien pire on l'a vu avec la décision
nissan en réalité ceux qui annonçaient
une catastrophe économique pour le
lendemain du référendum raconter
n'importe quoi parce que le lendemain du
référendum le royaume uni était toujours
membre de l'union européenne
mais il est évident que dès l'instant où
les relations entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne devienne devienne
catastrophique mais c'est très clair que
si vous êtes une multinationale dont
l'objectif est de servir le marché
intérieur
vous n'avez vous n'allez plus vous
implémentez au royaume uni et donc pour
le royaume uni les décisions
d'investissement qui vont tomber dans
les mois et les années qui viennent vont
je pense systématiquement tomber du côté
des vingt-sept et donc ça pour le
royaume uni ce sera extrêmement
dommageable au soleil le royaume uni n'a
pas encore compris qu'ils ne sont plus
une superpuissance mondiale
ce temps là est révolu le temps de
l'empiré britannique est révolu le
royaume uni ça pour cent la population
mondiale
et ça a marché qui est intéressant sans
plus on évoque souvent un sentiment
d'exaspération aujourd'hui du côté des
européens des responsables politiques
des diplomates peut-être aussi de vos
collègues parlementaires vous
vous confirmez absolument et en fait ce
qui est le plus le plus exaspérant
c'est le jeu à la fois theresa may mais
aussi de jeremy que robin le leader des
travaillistes le principal parti
d'opposition dont on voit bien que la
seule préoccupation c'est de garder un
semblant d'unité de leur parti et tout
le reste tout le reste est subordonnée à
cela que le royaume uni s'effondre
économiquement que les relations avec
l'union européenne se durcissent pendant
des années rien enfin tout cela ne leur
fait rien du moment qu'ils gardent un
semblant d'unité de leur parti c'est
pour ça évidemment si il ya une majorité
à la chambre des communes pour une
solution négociée et raisonnable mais
construire cette majorité suppose de la
part des deux grands partis de s'auto
dynamité en fait de se défaire leurs
propres unités et l'inde
theresa may veut garder le 10 downing
street jeremy kirby ne veulent conquérir
et la conque la condition pour cela
c'est de garder à partie au moins
apparemment unis merci à vous philippe
lambert c'est de nous livrer votre
regard sur cette question cet enjeu du
brésil
on va à présent s'intéresser à un sujet
qui alimente tous les fantasmes la
question des lobbys bruxelles concentre
le plus grand nombre de lobbyistes au
kilomètre carré après washington
ces lobbyistes ils interviennent à tous
les niveaux des institutions européennes
la commission le conseil et bien entendu
le parlement les eurodéputés viennent de
voter de nouvelles règles pour imposer
plus de transparence sur les échanges
qu'ils peuvent avoir avec ces groupes d'
influence on en parle avec nos invités
juste après ce sujet
[Musique]
le vote est secret le vote est ouvert
c'est une situation pour le moins
paradoxale
ce jour là les eurodéputés votent à
bulletin secret pour imposer plus de
transparence sur un sujet qui nourrit
tous les soupçons les lobbys le groupe
des verts veut obliger les présidents de
commissions et les rapporteurs a publié
la liste des lobbyistes qu'ils
rencontrent mais la droite allemande et
contre pour que chacun se sente libre de
son vote
elle impose un scrutin à bulletins
secrets déclenchant la colère de
plusieurs parlementaires
on a demandé un vote secret sur les
amendements qui prévoient plus de
transparence
le secret dans la transparence c'est
magnifique d'un point de vue politique
il y a toujours quelque chose pour nous
étonner
ce règlement devient une farce un triste
spectacle qui discrédite tout le
parlement faisait partie le vote est
secret également le vote est ouvert mais
la droite allemande va manquer son
objectif le vote est clos
malgré le secret du vote l'amendement
passe à quatre voix près
c'est adopter
[Applaudissements]
désormais chaque citoyen saura quel
lobby sont intervenus pour peser sur les
sujets dont débat le parlement
les ong saluent une avancée
[Musique]
nous avons milité depuis le début pour
que tous les députés européens soient
obligés d'appliquer ces mesures mais il
n'y avait pas de majorité au parlement
pour cela donc c'est un plus petit
compromis mais ça concerne des
parlementaires qui ont des
responsabilités beaucoup de députés
occupe ces fonctions donc c'est très
important que ces députés là soient
soumis à une transparence particulière
ces règles s'imposent aux députés les
plus exposés aux pressions des lobbys
notamment ceux qui rédige les rapports
parlementaires
ces pressions nous avions pu les
constater lors d'un reportage fin 2015
karima delli était alors rapporteur sur
la question des mobilités durables
elle nous expliquer comment le lobby de
l'industrie automobile arrivait à faire
passer certains amendements
donc vous voyez bien karima delli
rapporteur et ils vont proposer ces
amendements l'ensemble des députés
à gauche le texte de départ celui de la
rapporteure il propose de réduire la
vitesse en ville à 30 km à droite
l'amendement conseillé par les
lobbyistes la limite de vitesse a tout
simplement disparu
l'amendement des lobbyistes sera votée
telle quelle par les députés qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'ils
orientent même des choix d'amendements
ça veut dire qu'ils orientent la loi est
ce qui est très grave parce que le but
de du législateur basse et défend
l'intérêt général et sûrement pas dans
intérêts privés
une efficacité redoutable qui s'explique
par la force de frappe des lobbys à
bruxelles on estime leur nombre à 30
milles soit un lobbyiste par
fonctionnaire européen
olivier o de man connaît parfaitement ce
milieu il fait visiter aux citoyens les
lieux d' influence de la capitale belge
son ong a même publié un guide
touristique lobby planète saint
spécialité à lui c'est le monde de
l'automobile
voici l'immeuble berlaimont le siège de
la commission européenne
c'est là où les 28 commissaire travaille
tous les jours ici au numéro 25
c'est le quartier général des lobbyistes
de volkswagen à bruxelles
l'entreprise a déclaré faire travailler
plus de 40 le beast et ils dépensent
plus de 3 millions d'euros par an en
lobbying pour influencer les décisions
européennes
ces dépenses progressent chaque année
car les enjeux de pouvoir sont énormes
les décisions prises ici s'impose à
plusieurs centaines de millions
d'habitants sur presque tout un
continent
[Musique]
et pour débattre de cette question des
lobbys en plateau avec nous pascal
durand bonjour josette eurodéputés verts
élu en france et c'est votre groupe
politique qui a défendu ces mesures qui
ont été adoptées par le par le parlement
européen
à nos côtés également charles goerens
bonjour vous faites partie de l'alliance
des démocrates et des libéraux pour
l'europe la ld eux qui l a pris position
contre ces mesures de transparence vous
ne vous expliquerai pourquoi dans
quelques instants
et puis paul du geiq bonjour alors vous
êtes vous-même lobbystes ici à bruxelles
et vous représentez le serbe qui est une
fédération de lobbyistes européen à
bruxelles
enfin de parler de ces nouvelles règles
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur ce vote à
bulletin secret qu'on a vu au début du
sujet un vote à bulletin secret charles
goerens vous comprenez que ça puisse
interpeller quand on débat justement de
la transparence des relations entre les
eurodéputés et les lobbyistes une
pratique absolument inappropriée même
sir est permise par le règlement si on
parle de transparence
enfin le départ et commandeur d'être
forte en secret c'est absolument
ridicule on voit deux groupes n'étaient
pas favorables au fait de voter à
bulletins secrets et non pas du tout
nous avons une opinion nous avons
affiché
nous avons dit clairement pourquoi vous
pascal durand comment vous expliquer ce
choix qui a été imposé à l'ensemble du
parlement
j'explique ce tout simplement par les
règles c'est un texte que personne
n'avait jamais utilisé cécile 20% des
parlementaires le demandent ces deux
droits et le groupe du ppe donc de la
droite représente plus de 20% à lui tout
seul donc il n'y avait pas de problème
juridique
la réalité c'est que faut être face à
fait stupide n'y a pas d'autres mots
pour à trois mois des élections
un moment où les citoyens ont des doutes
sur la défense de l'intérêt général dans
les institutions de demander un vote à
bulletin secret uniquement sur la
question de la transparence par rapport
aux lobbys c'était une aberration
ça vient d'ailleurs d'un député de chez
monsieur urban hongrie qui a été repris
par la cd ou allemandes
ça n'est pas étonnant il ya on voit bien
là les liens avec l'industrie et les
liens avec la volonté de cacher des
choses
alors avant ce vote il y avait déjà des
règles qui encadrent et l'intervention
des groupes de pression au sein du
parlement européen paul ou jacques
vous les connaissez très bien ces règles
puisque vous devez les respecter ce que
vous pouvez nous les nous les présenter
en quelques mots
bien sûr
donc les règles en fête consiste en
l'enregistrement au sein d'un registre
de transparence qui existe depuis 2011
et qui est géré conjointement par la
commission européenne et le parlement
européen
est ce que fait le régime de
transparence en fait c'est de
répertorier les différents acteurs qui
tentent d'influencer le processus
législatif et donc ça permet de savoir
les intérêts qui sont défendues pour qui
par qui et avec quel budget est ici donc
il ya une nécessité de s'enregistrer si
vous voulez avoir accès au parlement
européen mais également de respecter un
code de conduite qui comprend donc
différentes règles à respecter notamment
ne pas tenter d'obtenir des informations
sous pression ou de manière frauduleuse
de toujours s'identifier lorsque l'on
prend rendez vous avec un député
européen est de toujours identifié le
client l'organisation l'entité que l'on
représente lorsqu'on discute d'un texte
avec un parlementaire européen
ces règles elle n'était pas suffisant
pascal durand à vos yeux là c'est pas
suffisant dans le sens où il n'y avait
pas d'obligation pour les députés de
dire qu'ils sont rencontrés nous la
question ou publics - le groupe des
verts les députés verts publient leurs
rencontres avec les lobbystes la
question c'est pas de rencontrer les
lobbystes parce que on travaille par
exemple sur l'automobile l'exemple de
karima delli est très clair il est
normal de rencontrer les constructeurs
automobiles quand vous avez à légiférer
sur l'automobile simplement ce qui est
normal et ça vient des dix c'est de
savoir au nom de qui ils parlent qu'ils
rencontrent et ce qu'il propose voilà
c'est juste de la transparence donc
cette transparence que vous avez fait
adopter au qu'est-ce que ça va changer
concrètement dans le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes dans le
fonction du parlement eh bien on va
savoir maintenant lorsque rapporteur et
lorsque les shadows rapporteur ciel
rapporteur de longues pour les groupes
travaillent sur un dossier on va savoir
qui ils ont rencontré tout simplement et
à quel rythme donc on va voir comme ça
là les volets des faluns que peut-être
que certains parlementaires n'auront
peut-être plus reprendre tels quels des
amendements présentés par les sadc pour
la danseuse s'agit en fait ça c'est un
autre sujet ce qu'elle également nous
nous battons c'est celui de l'empreinte
législatifs c'est-à-dire que moi par
exemple quand j'ai fait un rapport
j'ai dit ce qui m'avait été proposé dans
le rapport
là aussi je comprend des constructeurs
automobiles proposent pourquoi pas des
amendements simplement il faut le savoir
et quand on publie un rapport il faut
dire voilà telle amende
a été proposée par tel groupe d'
influence ça peut être aussi une ong
les ong elles ont aussi un rôle de
brûler le vent ne sont pas que nos
représentants à que gad et les
entreprises privées des secteurs
professionnels il ya des syndicats de
salariés il ya des ong
également ils sont presque présents ici
officieusement cessé mais quand vous
avez à prendre une décision je parle
évidemment sous mon plus beau coup drôle
de mot de mon collègue
il est évident que nous on ne sait pas
tout donc on a besoin de rencontrer des
gens on a besoin d'avoir les
informations
la seule chose et ça c'est très
important c'est qu'ils parlent au nom de
qui voilà alors charles goerens
expliquez nous pourquoi vous vous êtes
opposés à ces nouvelles mesures
parce que je crois qu'il est illusoire
de croire qu'on va maintenant tout
savoir
on ne saura pas tout il est écrit dans
le règlement qu'on devra mentionner le
nom des députés qui qui son rapporteur
qui sont donc dans une fonction exposé
qui ils ont rencontré dans les réunions
prévues donc de kadiolo meeting ça veut
dire que si vous rencontrez quelqu'un à
l'extérieur voulu serrer la main il
s'engage dans une discussion il peut
très bien assez de vous influencer
est ce qu'il faut le mentionner de mon
point de vue si on veut être totalement
transparent
il faudrait le faire vous voulez rire ou
en fait on peut contourner ces nouvelles
règles un coup de fil un parlementaire
européen
elles sont facilement contournable moi
je n'ai pas besoin d'un d'être enfermé
dans un carcan pour me dire comment je
dois me comporter
je suis rarement d'ailleurs contacté par
des gens qui ont des vues a exposé sur
les tabous tels sujets
j'ai été une fois j'ai reçu un appel
j'étais en déplacement et c'était une
quelqu'un qui travaille dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
parce que j'étais rapporteur syrie bola
dangers d'écouter monsieur on ne va pas
commencer la discussion
si vous avez des choses me suggérer
envoyez la à la présidente la commission
parce que moi je suis rapporteur d'une
commission parlementaire et je voudrais
que tous mes collègues aient le même
niveau de savoirs et de connaissances
sur ce sujet que le rapporteur si vous
êtes en train de dire que ces nouvelles
règles vous ne votez pas parce qu'elles
vont pas assez loin mais constitue quand
même marrant parce en guerre parce que
ça confère de la fausse sécurité c'est
de la fausse transparence l'espoir vont
rentrer chez soi on vide les poches et
d'écarter visite vous ne savez plus qui
vous les a donnés
donc je crois qu'il ya tellement de
failles dans celui qui veut vraiment se
prêter au trafic d'influencé il pourra
le faire
paul ou jacques alors cela va peut-être
surprendre nos téléspectateurs mais vous
en tout cas la fédération de lobbyistes
que vous représentez elle était
favorable à ces nouvelles mesures
expliquez nous pourquoi tout à fait donc
ses apps en accord avec d'autres
organisations et dont transparency
nationaux étaient en faveur de davantage
de transparence au niveau européen et
donc nous étions en faveur de la
publication des rendez vous entre
lobbyistes et de ses députés
mais nous avons également été déçus que
le texte n'aille pas plus loin et
notamment sur l'obligation pour les
présidents de commissions pour les
rapporteurs et les rapporteurs de
l'ombre de ne rencontrer que des
lobbyistes enregistrés sur leur site de
transparence ça vous fait sourire pascal
durand est parce que c'est une
obligation pour le groupe des verts nous
n'avons nous pas le droit de rencontrer
des lobbies qui ne sont pas inscrits sur
le registre tout simplement parce que
leur prix c'est une question de ré de
moi j'entends ce que dit monsieur grave
évidemment il ya toujours des gens qui
peuvent détourner je ne sais pas parce
qu'il ya des gens brûlent les feux
rouges qu'on va pas installer des feux
rouges à des carrefours
bien sûr qu'il ya des gens qui est bien
sûr qu'il ya des gens qui s'arrêterait
quoi qu'il arrive même sans feu rouge
pour laisser passer les piétons
mais non on est obligé de légiférer au
niveau global et donc pas regarder
uniquement les personnalités qui ont une
conscience très forte vous à londres
était quand même qu'il a tellement
d'échappatoire qu'il ait des faits s'est
dotée de là
la sincérité de sa disposition on avance
on avance monsieur reims en réalité on
essaye de faire en sorte que la
transparence petit à petit gagne les
institutions le parlement européen était
très en avance avec le registre des
lobbyistes bien bien plus que dans
beaucoup de pays notamment la france qui
maintenant commencent à s'aligner
on était en avance là on a failli
marquer un arrêt finalement on a une
avancée et j'espère qu'on en aura
d'autres effectivement alors que les oui
et les joueurs exemple dans mon pays les
chambres professionnelles font partie du
système législatif
ils peuvent même déposé des propositions
de loi si je rencontre le président de
la chambre de commerce
donc voilà même directeur de l'industrie
sidérurgique
est-ce que je rencontre lobbyistes ou de
ne pas le colonisateur mais quelqu'un
qui est impliquée dans le processus
législatif
donc il ya quand même beaucoup de choses
à discuter et à préciser j'ai très très
clair moi quand je rencontre quelqu'un
qui peut avoir un lien avec un dossier
sur lequel je travaille je le publie je
ne fais rien d'autre
je publie mon rendez vous et si
effectivement je rencontre le président
d'une société
je lui dis c'est tout il n'ya rien de
rien de choquant cela est encore une
fois je pense qu'il faut pas non plus
aller dans la paranoïa la plus totale
parce qu'on croise quelqu'un dans la rue
non c'est simplement quand on parle d'un
dossier sur lequel on travaille on le
dit voilà c'est tout pour essayer de
comprendre comment fonctionnent ces
activités de lobbying dans l'est dans le
cadre des institutions européennes
comment ça se passe concrètement si vous
êtes en charge d'un dossier bout de
combien de temps les premiers
représentants en affaires publiques
viennent vous voir et comment ce cas là
on attaque très vite parfois même en
amont est-ce que nous ne sommes pas
autosaisie stay en général c'est la
commission qui nous saisit par un projet
texte et rêve de la commission et ils
savent pas ce qu'ils travaillent déjà
avec la commission les lobbies qui le
savent que ce texte va être amené à l'or
il ya deux types de lobbies qui à ceux
qui en amont essaye de faire en sorte
que certains députés avec lesquels ils
ont l'habitude de travailler soient
désignés par leur groupe
ça c'est le mauvais l'aube il celui là
c'est le lobbysme j'allais dire est
exactement celui que vous dénoncez et
puis il ya le bon il ya ceux qui vous
appelle en disant je sais que vous allez
travailler sur le dossier
blop vous allez parler de l'homologation
des véhicules moi je suis constructeurs
où je suis ong en charge des problèmes d
mission des véhicules je souhaite avoir
un rendez vous avec vous voilà ça se
passe exactement comme ça et au fur et à
mesure du rapport pareil monsieur
monsieur jacques est ce qu'il ya des
limites que vous vous fixez dans le
cadre de votre travail définit
frontières que vous ne franchissait pas
bien sûr des limites donc il ya les
codes de conduite qui sont aussi bien le
code de conduite du registre de
transparence que du code de conduite de
ces apps notamment qui n'ont qu'un un
code de conduite obligatoires avec des
règles et respecté qui sont monsieur
durand l'a mentionné donc une
identification du client de
l'organisation sur lequel on représente
également de ne pas tenter d'avoir des
informations dont on ne devrait pas être
en possession respecter les informations
confidentielles ne pas diffuser de
fausses informations
ce sont des règles on me dira éthique
morale aussi des individuels et en plus
de ça naturellement de respecter la loi
le code pénal ce sont des logiques
naturellement que les lobbyistes
respecte monsieur rens
est-ce que selon vous les parlementaires
européens peuvent se passer aujourd'hui
des lobbyistes dans leur travail au
quotidien
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas devenu lobby
dépendant en quelque sorte
si tel était le cas il faudrait songer à
l'accès aux connaissances et aux savoirs
techniques certes on dispose et doubiste
il faudrait rééquilibrer cela sans fil
vous servent un petit peu d'experts vous
croiser les regards avec des points de
vue différents des intérêts différents
ça ils peuvent venir assister à des
colloques des séminaires ici au
parlement européen ce que je veux c'est
que la politique ne peut pas fonctionner
sans contre-pouvoir si le savoir est
monopolisé par paris lobbystes s'est
passé c'est malsain
si la commission ou le parlement ne
dispose pas du même niveau de
connaissance c'est marc st moi ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya un réflexe
récurrent au parlement il ya une
américanisation de nos comportements
c'est qu'il y a un problème on croit
pouvoir de résoudre avec une nouvelle
règle une nouvelle loi essaie de se
bercer d'illusions ou va régler un
problème avec cette pratique c'est
illusoire
encore une fois je n'ai pas besoin de me
comporter correctement en suivant ma
conscience et en prenant ces quelques
précautions que j'applique à moi même
depuis le début de mon mandat
ces précautions sont les suivantes quand
je le sois quelqu'un j'ai toujours un
oeil très calmes et à mes côtés pour
pouvoir toujours témoigner de la bonne
foi et je crois qu'il serait bon aussi
que chaque rapporteur affirmé devant la
commission parlementaire qu'il a été
correcte en toute circonstance je crois
que ça se serait déjà plus que cette
réglementation qui a quand même beaucoup
d' échappatoire
dernière question pour vous pascal
durand ce serait quoi l'étape d'après la
prochaine étape pour avancer sur cette
question là l'étape d'après ça serait
d'abord que tous les lobbyistes qui
travaillent
j'allais dire dans dans la périphérie de
bruxelles tous les lobbyistes
on a parlé d'un peu plus de 10 milles
sur le registre ou pensent qu'à leurs
demis et 10000 entités mais dont je
perçois non mais après il ya ça on a un
problème avec les cabinets d'avocats je
le dis d'autant plus librement que je
suis avocat on a un problème avec les
représentations parce que nom du secret
professionnel
parfois on ne sait pas au nom de qui ils
parlent donc ça c'est pas normal
voilà et puis faire en sorte qu' on est
l'empreinte légistatives celle dont
parlait tout à l'heure karima delli à
savoir que lorsque des amendements nous
sont proposés par des entités qui
représente des intérêts privés
ça soit connue et publiée en tant que
telle comme ça si on les retrouve dans
les textes de lois au moins on sait d'où
ils viennent très bien merci à vous
messieurs europe hebdo s'arrête là pour
pour aujourd'hui vous pouvez revoir
cette émission à la demande sur les
sites dès le cp de public sénat et de la
rtbf des semaines à tous et à bientôt
[Musique]